me gustaría hablarles un poco sobre el
carbono y cómo es que se recicla a
través de nuestra biosfera ya hemos
hablado sobre esto en otros vídeos pero
cuando hablamos de elementos como el
carbono estos no aparecen y desaparecen
de repente en nuestra biosfera en
realidad han estado presentes desde el
principio pero se reciclan de una forma
a otra y eso ocurre con el carbono y
bueno para entender la importancia del
carbono en nuestra biosfera y
especialmente en la vida aquí les tengo
algunos ejemplos de moléculas
importantes que contienen carbono
miren todas estas moléculas de color
negro son los carbonos esta molécula es
glucosa azúcar común es de donde podemos
obtener mucha energía por acá tenemos el
atp que es en donde se almacena la
energía en sistemas biológicos y por acá
tenemos uno de muchos aminoácidos los
aminoácidos construyen nuestras
proteínas
y por acá tenemos el adn y en todos
estos ejemplos podemos ver el papel que
juega el carbón a veces es difícil verlo
porque se encuentra muy cerca del centro
de las moléculas pues generalmente el
carbono forma el esqueleto o columna
vertebral de las moléculas ya que es un
elemento muy ordenado que puede formar
cuatro enlaces y así es como puede
lograr estas estructuras tan
impresionantes pero la pregunta es cuál
es el ciclo del carbono a través de
nuestra biosfera bueno podemos verlo tan
simple o tan complejo como queramos pero
en términos muy muy simples bueno así es
como mi cerebro piensa en el ciclo del
carbono podemos imaginar que el carbono
en nuestra atmósfera que principalmente
se encuentra en la forma molecular de
dióxido de carbono
este es el co2 nuevamente el carbono
está en el centro unido a 2 oxígenos y
hay mucho que podemos decir sobre el co2
pues el carbono es muy importante para
los seres vivos de hecho nuestros
cuerpos contienen de 18 a 19 por ciento
de carbono por masa entonces
el carbono es muy importante para los
sistemas biológicos y aún con el papel
que juega el dióxido de carbono en el
calentamiento global en realidad sólo
representa un pequeño porcentaje en
nuestra atmósfera miren es solo el 0.04
por ciento del gas presente en la
atmósfera porque en realidad la mayor
parte de nuestra atmósfera consiste en
nitrógeno el 78% pero no hablamos mucho
de eso mientras que el oxígeno
representa el 21 por ciento y también
tenemos otros elementos y moléculas pero
bueno la versión más simple del ciclo
del carbono es
ya tenemos este dióxido de carbono en la
atmósfera
tenemos dióxido de carbono molecular
flotando en el aire y existen ciertos
autótrofos como las plantas vamos a ver
este es el suelo y aquí tenemos una
planta en crecimiento
este es el tallo esta es su hoja aquí
tenemos otra hoja y las plantas pueden
crecer porque son capaces de tomar la
energía luminosa es decir la energía
proveniente del sol y usan esa energía
para fijar el carbón ahora fijar el
carbono suena un poco elegante pero
literalmente consiste en tomar el
dióxido de carbono molecular del aire y
fijar el carbono para formar las
diferentes moléculas de la planta que le
dan a la planta su estructura y energía
entonces esa masa de la planta y bueno
de hecho junto a mí tengo una planta y
crece por por aire la masa no aparece
mágicamente
sino que está tomando una masa del aire
y eso es lo que permite a esta planta
que siga creciendo entonces bueno como
habíamos dicho algunos carbonos estarán
presentes en forma de proteínas
aminoácidos e incluso formarán
componentes estructurales o también
pueden estar presentes en forma de
grasas y también en forma de energía
pero podemos imaginar a los animales que
no pueden hacer esto no pueden llevar a
cabo la fotosíntesis así que se querrán
comer estas plantas para obtener energía
en otros vídeos si hablamos sobre el
ciclo alimenticio entonces ésta podría
ser yo comiéndome una ensalada quiero
comerme esta planta quiero comerme esta
planta por el azúcar que contiene tal
vez sea una manzana o algo parecido y
eso le da a mi cuerpo energía para vivir
crecer y conforme yo metabolizó esa
glucosa por ejemplo la glucosa es una de
las moléculas que
puede formar la planta al tomar el
carbono del aire y entonces yo puedo
procesar esa glucosa de la planta que me
acabo de comer y mientras hago eso voy a
liberar dióxido de carbono
entonces libero el co2 de regreso al
aire y podemos ver que aquí hay un ciclo
miren el co2 es liberado por las cosas
que estan metabolizando estas moléculas
orgánicas y después puede ser fijado
nuevamente por los autótrofos que tienen
la capacidad de almacenar la energía del
sol en estos enlaces al fijar este
carbón pero existen otras formas en las
que puede ocurrir este ciclo por ejemplo
el co2 puede ser absorbido por el océano
se puede absorber en el océano y el
océano puede formar carbonato aquí
tenemos el carbono que está unido a 3
oxígenos el carbonato de calcio es un
constituyente clave en cosas como las
conchas y con el tiempo conforme las
conchas se rompen y se muelen con la
presión pueden formar caliza esta es la
caliza y se forma gracias a que el
dióxido de carbono es absorbido en el
océano seres vivos usan el carbonato de
calcio es decir el carbonato en
conjunción con el calcio para formar
estas conchas que después se caen al
fondo del mar y con el tiempo forman
estas estructuras rocosas y podemos
tener situaciones en las que los seres
vivos por ejemplo ya hablamos de los
autótrofos como las plantas o de otros
seres como yo que nos comemos a las
plantas bueno una vez que todos los
seres morimos y que la materia orgánica
no se ha descompuesto
en el suelo dibujaré la planta dibujaré
la planta porque no impacta tanto como
si me dibujo a mí supongamos que esta es
la planta bueno con suficiente presión y
tiempo aunque muchas veces en el proceso
de descomposición se puede liberar un
poco de carbono pero con el tiempo esto
se comprimirá y se convertirá en un
combustible fósil entonces cuando vean
petróleo o cuando quemen gasolina que es
simplemente una refinación del petróleo
en realidad eso es materia orgánica esa
energía que pueden almacenar las plantas
a partir de la energía luminosa y que
vivieron hace millones o decenas de
millones de años pero si tomamos ese
mismo combustible fósil del suelo que
ahora ocurre mucho porque lo necesitamos
para que funcionen muchas cosas bueno si
lo sacamos si lo quemamos déjenme
dibujar un ejemplo de eso supongamos que
tenemos un frasco de petróleo pero no lo
voy a dibujar
color negro porque si no no lo van a ver
y si lo quemamos si lo quemamos el
proceso de combustión y bueno no
necesariamente tiene que ser petróleo
por ejemplo podríamos quemar un pedazo
de madera entonces si tomamos esa
materia orgánica se rompen estos enlaces
carbono-carbono de alguna forma pueden
decir que ocurre el proceso inverso de
la fotosíntesis en este proceso se
rompen los enlaces y se libera el carbón
es liberado en forma de dióxido de
carbono que en teoría puede ser fijado
nuevamente entonces la idea general es
que cuando los autótrofos como las
plantas realizan su fotosíntesis pueden
fijar el carbono y después éste puede
ser quemado en un proceso de combustión
con lo que se libera el carbono de
regreso a la atmósfera o también puede
ser que los animales se coman la planta
y que su metabolismo es decir mientras
rompen los enlaces carbono-carbono
tienen energía para hacer lo que
necesitan hacer y al mismo tiempo
liberan dióxido de carbono